hi i'm rio i'm the owner of kim sushame
repair and also i'm running on youtube
channel repair studio i'm doing a
resolution on a pair of brown stone
boots that retail for around 200.
brown stones have ballooned in
popularity in listened ears the leather
uppers are really high quality and the
non-sleeve outsoles provide excellent
traction in icy conditions one of my
customers brought me these boots for
installation
they are muddy and dirty and also heels
are worn out from ears of use
i'm brushing away loose beverages with a
soft hair brush to remove crusty mud and
dirt
because these levers can make scratches
on leather while destroying pooch
the mod is mostly around the toe box
area
since that's the most common area you
can kick dart of
the heel of boots is naturally worn out
after years of wear
now i'm slowly cutting the outline of
the heel
with a cutting knife to remove the top
part of heel you have to cut off the old
heel area as the thickness of new heel
plate
i'm sanding the cutter paste of the heel
to make it flat so that new heel plates
sits well as they are attached together
i'm using a glue brush to apply a
polyurethane adhesive to glue a new
rubber heel plate
these lower tank heels are very durable
and less stunt
its logos design makes them more
aggressive to the ground
i'm drying the glue five to ten minutes
to allow the solvent in the adhesive to
paperweight
this allows the glue to adhere better
[Music]
now i'm covering the excess material off
of the heel plate with a cutting knife
sanding the edge of new hill plate to
make it smooth and clean
i'm applying leather cleaner with a
horsehair brush to clean the boots
and i'm scrubbing harder than normal
shoes because these boots are muddy
the interior of the boots is dirty as
well so i'm going to clean the inside of
the boots too
now i'm using a cotton wool pad with a
leather propeller to degrade the wood
when you re-dye shiny boots you have to
love your boots with a leather propeller
to remove the existing finishes such as
wax oil and polish
the grazer is a special mix of chemicals
used to thoroughly clean leather
the boots have become faded so i'm going
to re-dye them
now i'm applying the dye with a big
paintbrush in order to efficiently cover
the full surface
you can use a paintbrush to cover the
grain from every direction
leaving no undyed area
i'm using a wool dabber to apply the
second coat of dye
applying two or three thin coats will
more likely desert in an even color
i'm applying shoe cream to boots to
nourish and recover them
[Music]
i'm quickly bopping the boots with the
horsehair brush to bring the shine back
keep the rest of my arm stationary while
my wrist quickly flicks the brush back
and forth and make sure to evenly brush
the surface of the boots
i'm applying shoe deodolizer into shoes
and it works by observing moisture and
replacing offensive smells with those
present scents
these boots were in bad condition when
they came to me
i'm very happy with how they came out
and i'm glad that my customer will get
to wear these boots for many more years
[Music]
you